welcome back to New rockstars and with
Secret Wars having been announced we
know that some crazy crossover fighting
between Heroes of different universes
are bound to happen much like it did in
the comics because it ain't called
Secret Wars for nothing baby but what if
I told you that scores won't take place
within the MCU 616 at all what if I told
you that Spirit Wars was going to pit
the fox X-Men against the Sony
Spider-Man this is Rogue Theory the
shower we pitch the wildest theories for
the nerdy tiles that we love a show made
possible by the support of nordvpn more
on those beautiful people in a minute my
name is mte Gregory with me today is the
wonderful Whitney van laningham what's
going on Whitney hi so uh uh it's me and
uh if you're listening to this podcast
it's my birthday the day that you listen
to this
so I'm recording it at age 31. the
podcast doesn't come out until I turn 32
so so yeah it's like you're listening to
a 31 year old right now but I'm a 32
year old while you're listening to it
isn't that wild you're listening to 31
year old Whitney talk but I'm 32. ah
it's so weird I travel oh my God baby we
love you so much thank you for surviving
for 32 years I know I can't believe I
did it either wild how am I not dead yet
but we also have a uh non-birthday boy
here friend of the show Tom Michaelson
how is it on your own birthday today Tom
oh great I'm a strapping young 56 and
I'm you know hanging in there trying to
make sure I stayed until 57 so thanks
for having me guys not not 31 but yeah
but you know we made it I woke up at 4am
went to McDonald's got my coffee and
I've been waiting Holding Out for my nap
to do the show so let's do it
if you're 56 I'm a monkey's uncle
it's I do feel like I'm like 60 and even
though I'm like 30 like my bones once
you hit 30 I feel like you you're just
your muscles start to go like you're
just I don't know your bones don't work
anymore your bones turn to that you know
like the squishy things when you like go
to like a gymnastic studio and you like
jump into that pit that's what your
thoughts become yeah like the foam
blocks but it hurts so they become like
like like that but not but painful uh so
anyone who's under there are you
listening to this get ready bone pit not
foam pit bone pit yeah
definitely
that's the name of my vagina am I right
ladies
I'm just kidding her name is Shirley
that's hilarious
but also my man big head gang brother
Tommy back to it what's going on Tommy
MTM 23 now but will I live to see 24 and
the way things is going I don't know
to say Wendy like a bottle of wine you
are aging so fine uh we celebrate you my
roommate I can't wait for you to come
into the office later today to give you
a birthday
hugs
snug why are you rubbing this in my face
you know I can't give Whitney hugs what
are you doing
we love so much though we made up for
last time hugging when you were in town
that was great come back I miss you
already I know come back yes I I miss
you guys so much but not during the
Cyclone yeah yeah
yeah but now it is time for our first
topic because I believe that the fox
X-Men will face off against the Sony
Spider-Man and villains in um the sea
Awards movie because this this theory is
based on a rumor that I saw on the
internet
um a couple of days ago it's a baseless
rumor we usually don't do rumors here on
new Roxas but I thought um it'd be a fun
it's real scary we can do whatever we
want yeah
your series are valid here exactly all
theories are valid and they're all true
here
um this is this is our Cinematic
Universe but no uh I think that it's a
really fun idea to have the the fox
X-Men and the Sony Spider-Man face off
in secret Wars while um you know the
Kang Dynasty will end up being like the
main Avengers Multiverse film
um that they end up doing
um because we know that in the secret
Wars event in the comics I'm a huge part
of what happened before Secret Wars was
the incursions uh where different Earths
were crossing over with each other and
basically one Earth has to the heroes of
one Earth has to fight the heroes of the
other Earth to to survive basically like
one Earth has to be destroyed it'd be
really cool to see the fox X-Men
Universe Crossover with the Sony
Spider-Man universe and like have them
duke it out and then the winner of that
Universe fight ends up fighting um the
MCU I think that'd be really fun uh what
do you what do you guys think well
Wolverine is gonna
[ __ ] up morbius he's gonna [ __ ] that guy
out morbius is not surviving against the
X-Men I'm sorry Jared Leto yeah no Jared
Leto is not surviving I thought you were
gonna say 30 other people before more of
you said that's how much morvis isn't
even on my own you're right listen when
I think Sony I think that it's morbin
time Tom and I think that you need to
get on board with that it's my birthday
and it's morbid you're right
he's gonna do some good and maybe some
good means he's getting sliced up by
Wolverine who knows honestly that would
be be a great way to never do a morbius
again if Jared Leto just gets ice this
might be amazing
I would literally pay twice yes that
would redeem so much they brought back
some people just you know for these
roles just to die off well Jared Leto's
the exact weirdo that would be on board
with that like he's like yes I will be
on the in this movie for five minutes
and then have my like throat slashed by
a wolverine claw and then die and that
will be it and then I can yeah but you
know that he's gonna get meta into that
role for like eight months beforehand
yeah
he's gonna move to like a commune and
Joshua tree and just practice being the
guy who dies five minutes in for like I
find a good spot outside and just lay
there for four months just just
practicing the death scene of getting
sliced he just pays like like a hobo
he's like hey just stab me in the neck I
just want to see how it feels I'll say
this so I'll say this to mg's point
imagine Tom Toby Andrew with Ray Topher
Tom Hardy Chaser as the two Venoms
behind them uh charging towards Rogue
Beast uh Wolverine Cyclops and Jean Gray
that's kind of that's an exciting uh
potential you know even if they did the
iconic X-Men 97 animation uh running
towards each other
I mean come on but we also have you know
we also have vulture we also have like
that bathroom like uh Team of bad guys
going good that they're setting up over
there uh the Disco that what was the new
movie that was just like announced the
Disco
that's right Hypno Hustler
we know that like Sony's having their
own little like villain universe that
they're building up with the with the
Venom verse like so I think that'd be
really dope to see that Universe face
off against the fox X-Men oh we also
have uh what's his name bad Bunny's
character right
and Craven Craven will be out by then
right exactly so that's happening and
you know speaking of fox I mean it's
more than just the X-Men really like you
because I was thinking this could be a
chance for Chris Evans to come back but
not his cat but as uh Human Torch what
if we had the Galactus cloud from
Fantastic Four two versus the
can we do like a draft of like fantasy
clown fighting where we draft all of our
favorite clouds dude favorite fighting
class oh my God I will pay 101 for that
movie
we gotta get out of here and start our
own Studio yeah what are we doing
but no like it's it would just be so
great like the possibility the Fantastic
Four from uh which is technically in
that fox X-Men Universe I believe yeah
you know Chris Evans like they could all
come back and like fight against
um the X-Men but not the X-Men um the
Spider-Man you could have the cool uh
Lawrence Fishburne Silver Surfer come
back to that that would actually be dope
seeing him because that was one of the
coolest parts of that entire franchise
is how nuts and weird he was remember he
was like morphing through his board and
like absorbing rockets and just so weird
and he could he could make like a movie
projector on his abs and like tell his
like whole life story
really cool like a Teletubby exactly so
I imagine him could be back could be
dope yeah who I think we should let in
on this little game
Wes Anderson because then we could have
the Fantastic Four Fight The Fantastic
Mr Fox and that [ __ ] would be sick
Nation against like superheroes
Fantastic Sams
Fantastic Sams yes
first first Rogue Fury of the year I'm
I'm going rogue on the point awarding
giving Whitney a rook or something
though
FX Sony and Wes Anderson present the
Fantastic verse
102 for that movie
but like okay well let's say like the
fox X-Men did face off against the Sony
verse which Universe do you guys think
would actually win in that scenario
oh that's tough because the X-Men are
like of course super powerful but I
think they I think this the Marvel verse
would have to win because I I I
unfortunately the behind the scenes part
will have to come to place like Halle
Berry probably doesn't want to keep
playing Storm but if she knows she'll be
part of the MCU and go out with a bang
and have a cool scene maybe she'd come
back for that you know I think that
would be the way to to bring all these
a-listers back to the for just one last
ride because you know only Hugh Jackman
got a kind of a send-off with Logan and
even he's getting to come back so maybe
other people might want to come back and
have their final moment with their
character and have something cool or
badass go down and I think you know it
would be a good opportunity for because
if they have like uh almost like a three
three factions at once right with Marvel
Sony and MCU fighting at once then you
could have the X-Men get some wins on
the Sony guys you know what I mean kill
some of them off and so they're not just
getting Merc left and right uh but I
think that would be the way to do it is
like because MCU is gonna is is what's
gonna survive it's survived already Fox
universe is dead but you could bring
those people back for one cool ass ride
I think that'd be badass yeah I'm with
it I think uh the hard thing is
defeating three spidermen right like I
mean though there's so many characters
you're kind of like yeah eventually you
know we know how to we know how to get
the symbiote suit to to detach from
Eddie and then that makes it more
vulnerable the killing three Spider-Man
seems almost impossible to me but yeah
especially when it's Toby Andrew and Tom
they're very powerful together so I I
give the slight advantage to the
Spiderman I would love for them to find
a way to bring back the different
generations of X-Men 2. imagine double
magnetos A Fastbender and a Ian McKellen
that's even older you can probably give
everybody a run for their money
um I want to see that guy from X-Men
three who can grow limbs come back yeah
he's like just throwing his lips he's
like the detachable little kid but like
not as a joke
even though he's just as ridiculous yeah
he's getting his lips chopped off by
everybody he's like come on come on I'd
like to see that guy he's like the black
he's like the Black Knight in uh exactly
imagine a scenario where the the younger
X-Men Fight the older X-Men like the the
two different X-Men fight because
um they're different timelines
essentially babies versus grown-ups dude
double beasts yeah Kelsey Grammer and
yeah they should do like a Rugrats in
Paris kind of thing yeah where they make
all the X-Men babies and then they let
them loose in a city
baby X-Men I would watch that what if
Episode and then the baby X-Men can
fight the Muppet Babies because
exactly and then the boss babies can
fight the Baby Geniuses oh [ __ ] the boss
babies have to fight them and they could
be fighting to the tune of baby shark
just to the Dead face
Avengers baby Wars
secret baby Wars
[Laughter]
version of that and it's secret because
none of their parents know that they can
talk just like in Rugrats yeah so that's
why it's a secret baby War very cool you
guys I think we just came up with like a
bunch of really good movies we just came
up with like eight franchises in like
eight minutes this is great eight
billion dollar franchises but all right
now it's time to vote on this crazy
theory of the Sony's Spider-Man universe
facing off against the fox X-Men
Universe do you guys think that this
theory is rogus bogus or ogis take it
away with me bro guess duh obviously I
just got so on board with this on every
level let's do it let's go let's have
[ __ ] morbius fighting Wolverine
that's what I want to see baby I want to
see it oh my God I want to see what
would happen if you if you drank
Wolverine's blood like would it become
immortal that would be great Woody
anyway but yes I don't know we don't
know we need to see it because we don't
know so we need to find out and then
what if he and Magneto get into some
time travel [ __ ] and then they merge
and then it's more Benito and then he
can suck blood and control metal
he just like just controls people it's
like lifts people up controls blood
that'd be so crazy yes exactly because
he can blood Bend he's just like a blood
Bender now I am on board this Bear's
guitar do it yeah so rogus rogus
obviously all right thank you one Rogue
is for Wendy what about your job I'm
gonna have to do I'm gonna have to do
rogue to double rogus because you know I
know we don't like to talk about rumors
and and conjecture but this is just too
fun of an idea to not get into it for
all the things that you're saying I mean
you know the cloud Wars uh you know uh
the Double mag needles double double
Venoms would be cool you know that would
give that would be a cool way to make
Topher Grace's Venom a little bit more
badass so yeah just too many cool
opportunities uh that you're never
really gonna have a story opportunity to
tell again outside of Secret Wars really
so I think we gotta have it we gotta do
it we gotta do it all right two rocuses
what do you think Tommy you know I was
gonna rain on this parade a little bit
and give you an August because I just
have a hard time believing that Marvel
or Disney Marvel would dedicate a giant
uh Team Up movie to not having any of
their IP I mean I guess the fox X-Men
are their IP now but they're not MCU
homegrown prospects they're like you
know things they acquired but
it's the new year and it's a new me and
I want the idea so I'm going
rogus yeah
24. so I think there's plenty of room at
the table for all of our friends and for
the record I was assuming they were
going to be in the same movie as the MCU
but I just realized are you saying Mt
that they might have their own separate
thing yeah basically I wanted to have
nothing to do with the MCU I want this
to be its own thing I was assuming it
would be like it would be like like the
end of end game times like 10 with
double clouds and everybody coming
together but yeah
MCU whatsoever no no mention of it they
don't even know what 616 is it's just
Magneto and Morpheus going head to head
I do agree with Tommy that like it's
very unlikely that the MCU would like
not like bring in 616 on this at all
um I think that 616 would be involved
but like I think it'd be really fun
still to have the the spider person
before
um having the winner face off against
the MCU that'd be really do but up next
Tommy uh the wonderful Thompson has his
own Rogue theory about the upcoming
Agatha coven of chaos show that I cannot
wait to listen to but first we want to
remind you to check out new
rockstarsbirch.com where you can pick
yourself up some new rock stars shirts
hats hoodies stickers pins and more look
at Whitney shirts Whitney is just
looking so good in that new Rockstar
most beautiful creature because of this
shirt it really is the most beautiful
creature on this planet before the shirt
and athletes even more so after the
shirt so yes the best way to find a
fellow new rock stars fan in the wild is
by spotting this merch in the wild so
let them know your love for new rock
stars and support the channel by
checking out all of our awesome Birch
options over at director'smerch.com but
we also want to thank our amazing
friends at nordvpn for sponsoring this
video because here at new rockstars we
are big fans of nordvpn and all of their
incredible features we spend a lot of
time online and Nora VPN offers so many
tools that improve your online
experience nor VPN is so easy to use
with one click just one nordvpn is up
and running or you can even enable auto
connect for zero click protection to
help you browse the internet safely you
don't even have to click once but so
that's the future we don't have to do
anything that you don't want to do with
over 5400 servers in 60 countries nor
VPN gives you access to games and
streaming platforms that currently are
not available in your region it's so
handy and the best part is nordvpn will
not slow down your online experience at
all they're very very hip like that
they've done the speed test and North
VPN is the fastest VPN out there be safe
on the internet and we recommend a VPN
and nordvpn is the best in the industry
grab your exclusive nordvpn deal by
going to nordvpn.com Rogue Theory to get
a huge discount off your nordvpn plan
plus four additional months for free
it's completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee get that
exclusive deal at nordvpn.com Rogue
Theory we also want to thank rocket
bunny for sponsoring this podcast do you
know how much your subscriptions cost
because most Americans think that they
spend around 80 a month on subscriptions
when the actual total is closer to 200
if you don't know exactly how much
you're spending every month then you
need rocket money rocket money formerly
known as true bill is a personal finance
app that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions that they forgot about
like that streaming service that you
bought to watch that one show on or that
free trial that you never even used
rocket money will quickly and easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
that you can stop paying for the ones
that you don't want simply find the
subscription that you don't want and
press cancel and Rocket money will
cancel it for you rocket money makes
canceling subscriptions as easy as a
click of a button over three million
people have used rocket money saving the
average person up to 720 a year so many
of us at new rockstars use rocket money
and it's helped us cancel those unwanted
subscriptions with no hassle so stop
throwing the money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions today and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com Rogue that is
rocketmoney.com rogue rocketmoney.com
rogue and we also want to thank battling
blades you know what makes Deadpool so
great it's not the jokes or even his
cool red uniform it's his swords his
blades if you want some Blades of your
own check out battling blades battling
blades designs and sales high quality
swords axes machetes and knives striving
to design and create products with the
highest quality Metals bone wood and
leather and it's more than just the
blades battling blades also sells armor
Shields and helmets to really get into
character looking for something a little
bit more personal battling blades will
take your custom order to make the blade
of your dreams seriously check out their
incredible sight and see everything that
they have to offer I've got my eyes on a
high carbon Damascus steel comma sword
so I can be the swashbuckler of Boston
that I've always dreamed of being just
go out on the streets and fight crime at
night with my big ass sword so for 20
off your battling blades order go to
battlingblades.com and enter code Rogue
at checkout that's a
b-a-t-t-l-i-n-glades.com and enter code
Roga checkout to get 20 off your order
and we think battling blades for
sponsoring this video podcast all right
gang it's time for our second topic you
guys ready let's do it because my boy
Tommy bechtold is about to blow our
minds with this Agatha House of Harkness
topic taken away Mr Thomas folks I'm
gonna come at you short and sweet today
with this Theory because it's so tight
and so right I may not even ask for a
vote I will just accept your nighting
approval we have to vote Tommy yeah
we'll see we're all getting hyped up for
Agatha House of Harkness and I am going
to tell you right now what that show is
gonna be about okay I know that uh we
may not necessarily know but I have some
intuitions I believe the story of Agatha
House of Harkness season one hopefully
of many is going to be a story about
freeing Wanda from The Nightmare world
now who is going to free Wanda our 616
Wanda from The Nightmare world that's
right she's not dead she's been trapped
by Nightmare he's snatched her from
Wonder core mountain now snatched who's
going to be freeing them Agatha and
wicked oh Agatha's a prisoner of her own
mind right now and Wiccan is presumably
never really existed and was taken away
it's not that Wicked guys this weekend
is Billy from earth838 The Billy we met
as a scared child in Multiverse of
Madness now why would Billy care about
this Wanda well Billy feels a link to
Wanda uh from his own trauma and
feelings of Abandonment from being a
child of divorce Wanda so badly wants
her kids the 838 implies that Wanda and
vision have divorced and are not
together therefore a billion want to are
living with their mother so I think that
that Billy witnessed that and and was
putting it out into the world with his
magic that he he sensed a connection to
that Wanda
who senses connections and makes deals
and trainings to help people with maybe
a little more of a
nefarious
uh uh intentions Mephisto enter Mephisto
he T he takes 838 Billy under his wing
and teaches him how to dream walk so
Billy escapes 838 by dreamwalking as
whatever the character Joe Locke is
going to be playing in the show the
actor Joe Locke in 616. so that
character goes to Agatha frees her from
her mental prison and then gathers a
covenant of chaos to go into the
nightmare world to battle nightmare who
is played by Aubry Plaza that's right
nightmare will be played by Aubry Plaza
the coven will be battling against
nightmare for Wanda's Soul uh and
bringing Wanda back to the 616 uh where
she and Joe Locke can be mother and son
time to maximoff has spoken there will
be no vote it's all Rogues
time to maximize
um wait wait you're Tom to maximoff and
I'm Scarlet wit that's so cute
I like us being friends Tommy this is
speaking of no notes I have no notes on
our friendship no no it's acceptable no
no it's no notes on any of our
friendships you guys I love all of you I
love this idea of like exploring uh
Billy in his magical abilities and like
sort of seeing him get get tempted by
the darker side of magic like that is
such a good idea
um and like him having this connection
with this other Wanda and like wanting
to to save her by working with like it's
such a it's such a unique idea that I'm
just like wow I would really love to see
this scenario at least in a what if
episode that we really don't oh yeah
what if Episode would be would be really
cool to see all this because they can do
a lot more more as far as like you know
traveling dimensions and powers and
stuff that would be hard to get I think
on Disney plus but yeah
oops I saved this one off sorry I found
this on the way she thought I said her
name that's Rhonda she's reaching out to
us what is reaching out to us from
beneath the ruins of juanagar
[Music]
what you said the two kids for that was
the first thing I thought Michael the
children do
the best part of the movie I love that
idea because you know as you were
talking I was also thinking maybe maybe
he felt a connection to her because he's
from a universe where he lost his mom
maybe it's not the a3a Tommy maybe it's
a 839 and then that one Wanda died and
he's and he's so he's having a similar
Arc to Wanda and Dr Strange except he's
not he doesn't have the dark hold he's
not evil he's not possessed by that so
he's actually good and he might have a
chance to bring her back and how cool
would it be for him to actually succeed
in finding you know another mom when she
couldn't find other kids because he
wasn't under the influence of the dark
hole that'd be really cool I like that a
lot and one other thing I meant I forgot
to mention about this Theory I fleshed
it out a little bit on the break room
the other day is the 838 has a weird
kind of anti-child vibe anyway if you
notice like when they were traveling
around the city of a3a there were no
children it was all adults walking
around and now my theory practicality
wise was they filmed that during covid
and hiring child extras might have been
an extra layer of difficulty so they
just had all background actors that were
adults but really Billy and Tommy are
the only children we saw in 838 Reed
Richards mentions being a father but he
does not we don't receive the kids there
are no other children shown in that you
would think there'd be some other kids
eating some uh you know pizza balls yeah
but yeah you're right yeah yeah why the
heck does pizza Papa exist if there
ain't no kids to gobble up those pizza
Papa balls he's a papa to No One the
pizza is made out of children do you not
get the application oh my God there's a
global cabal that eats the adrenochrome
red beans yeah red beans go and we eat
children and they threatens their Pizza
gate Pizza ball game
oh my God but no I'm gonna give this
Theory a a double roguez because super
Rogue all right I really love this idea
of Billy
um just really tapping into that that
really dark side of magic and um and
dream walking like his mom I picked up
really dope I'll give it a double rocus
what do you guys think I'm gonna give it
a rogus for two reasons the first reason
being very selfish which is that I also
had a theory that Wanda survived and was
in a different dimension that I did a
video on like a year ago when Multiverse
event has came out and if Tommy is right
about this that means I'm right and then
next year when we do the what we got
wrong videos this will be my thing I got
right and I'll remember it this time
yeah
um so that's selfishly number one why I
want this to be right
but number two I do think that we could
see this it is really realistic because
um and I'm blanking on the name of the
comic book please don't kill me internet
it's sitting on my coffee table right
now and I'm just blanking but it's the
the one where Wanda does get displaced
after House of M when she gets displaced
to like a different kind of it's not a
different reality but it's like she gets
displaced basically and she forgets who
she is and she like forgets that she's
the Scarlet Witch and I feel like they
are going to incorporate elements from
that storyline into the MCU and have
Wanda have been displaced after her
death and she's not really dead maybe
she just can't remember exactly who she
is or maybe she's trapped like Tommy's
saying maybe she has to be broken free
from The Nightmare Zone I think that's a
rogus's hell Theory and uh I hope you're
right
um I you know I I like this Theory and I
was gonna give a thumbs up oh no but I'm
gonna give it two thumbs up
and it was great
you know wrote theories to get like
inspired about and get excited about
these movies and about the potential of
it and this is a freaking awesome idea
that I hadn't even thought about or
thought of like there's so many shows on
the horizon that Agatha Covenant of
Darkness isn't necessarily immediately
in front of me so I hadn't even thought
of it but to incorporate Tommy and to
incorporate Nightmare and even did
casting for the cast that's been
announced like this is a very well
thought out flesh out idea that deserves
two Rogues
10 out of 10 casting choices I love that
dude that'd be sick especially because
did you guys watch her in uh in Legion
she was so spooky
you know I want to see her get hardcore
like that I thought you're gonna say
White Lotus yeah I was like oh yes also
White Lotus she was all so spooky in
that all right guys this brings us to
our Rogue question you guys are ready
for this one oh yeah hit me with it baby
because the word around Hollywood is at
the search for a new James Bond is it
really heating up with Aaron
Taylor-Johnson being presented as a
potential front-runner to take over the
iconic role so I want to hear your
guys's rogus picks for a new James Bond
go super Rogue with this one I
personally would love to see Kermit the
Frog
I'm glad you said that because my pick
is one of the descendants of the Saint
Bernard dog Beethoven to play James bone
I say why did it why is it got to be a
human James bone I like my water dish
shaken not stirred I
yeah it'll be a golden retriever it'll
be a Golden Retriever and he kills
people died
everybody gets murked imagine a golden
retriever sprinting on top of a train as
it's going into a tunnel and you have
this drone shot a wide coming around as
this train's like careening and this
dog's chasing a guy on a train car you
just sold me Tommy this is amazing are
you making me do big
what if it's a little plug and it's Miss
money puggy Miss money
buggy oh my God we have so many like
million dollar ideas today this is the
one that Kevin need to watch because oh
yeah this is this is where the next the
next 10 years of movies are being made
right here folks Barbara broccoli if
you're watching it's all about kittens
bones Babs broccoli I can't believe it's
a real person's name I saw that and I
thought it was a joke yeah it was like
this is Barbara broccoli everybody
remembers where they were the first time
they found out Barbara Brockley is a
real person right now and I'm like what
that's a real person yes I found out on
slack the other day in what context she
does she work at Starbucks like who no
they own the James Bond uh uh brand
basically wait Barbara broccoli owns
James Bond yes Barbara it is broccoli
the VeggieTales Universe
James Bond is a Christian vegetable now
and you guys are all gonna like it
careful he doesn't get laid anymore he
saves him for marriage as God intended
that's right that's the new James Bond
and Tom be careful if you investigate
this too much you could be known as a
stalker oh celery
uh you don't want to get through Steam
you don't want to get too steamed over
this I can imagine him I can imagine him
in this Infamous Bond hooking up uh
scene and being like ever eat your
vegetables today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh man I forgot I thought the I forgot
that the Air Bud was such a good idea I
was like that's a great idea then I was
like that's my idea I forgot I didn't
even come up with one
um okay I was like the boofing ball and
he helped me flesh out this whole world
we did it together we did it this will
be a group effort what this would be a
air air Bond air Bond will be our answer
for today I love that so much Wendy okay
my answer
is
obviously p Davidson because he keeps
pulling [ __ ] and it's like what how
why at least if he was James Bond it
would make sense and these [ __ ] will
be dogs because it's still part of the
air Bond universe
and
James bone I'll I'll tie mine back to
that where okay I'll uh I don't think
anyone uh got this because I was one who
mentioned VeggieTales so I'll say uh the
Cucumber from Veggie Tales can be the
yes
you can have your vegetables and eat it
too there you go vegetable James Bond is
a really good call I
virginal vegetable James Bond and it
could be yeah it could be Pete Davidson
a vegetable and a dog and a dog those
are they're all three in the casting
office and they're just like so you up
for the you know for Bond yeah me too my
agent yes it's pretty good
starts sweating he's like I don't know I
don't know I don't know if I can measure
up to a cucumber and a dog but no I
would love to see Pete David he's
basically the American Bond at this
point he's bedded all of our starlets
at this point we're all Eskimo brothers
with Pete Davidson
seriously it's either Pete Davidson or
Nick Cannon Nick Cannon yeah Nick Cannon
is possibly the only person who gets
laid more than Pete David said yeah if
there's an apocalypse we need to make
sure he and his family survives because
he can repopulate the world oh he can
repopulate the entire he's like the
Genghis Khan of the 20th century
21st century Abraham over here I'm gonna
I'm gonna give the Rogue question the
road points of course to the the Air
Buddy uh Universe
a good Bond so Tommy wins the question
trophy Rogue trophy for today because we
all love the roguest of us all Tommy
back told in all of you I love each and
every one of you because I love it with
you guys every week just being silly and
and Rogue and nerdy but that is it for
this episode of Rogue Theory thanks to
our amazing guest Whitney van learning
him Tom Michaelson and Tommy Beck told
go follow them all on their Twitters
they're all amazing people and you can
support our Channel by checking out all
of our awesome merch over at New
rockstarsmerch.com you can follow me at
mastertonment on Twitter if you want to
see me I'll tweet some weird [ __ ] you
follow new rockstars and all social
platforms and be sure to subscribe to
our channel here on the youtube.com we
love you guys so much thank you guys for
spending time with us and we'll see you
guys next time bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]